bella tutti ragazzi perché sono video
sono familiari sono con il signor gatto
e siamo trovati su lodi tra plant ii
continuiamo a dove eravamo rimasti
ragazzi allora anche noi ma dobbiamo
stare per la tv possibili terroristi non
è detto maledizione difficile non è vero
ma perché solo io non riesco a fare le
cose mio dio ce l'ho fatta dopo un'ora e
mezza signor gattola finisca la prego
perfetto per metto ce l'ho fatta signor
gatto equa ma anche lì e ci ero arrivato
solo remo è quello che è adesso in
appalto forse sì
eccolo ma non vada ma non è potente dai
tornano a lei fi squadra è stato
veramente in crisi e che ha ospitato un
ora in mente poi sbagliato nel modo più
stupido fiero già oltre con la testa ero
già oltre la ferrario per gioco una
mamma mia ma perché non mi salta più uno
madonna ragazzi sta parte potrebbe
essere molto più difficile di quanto
pensassi ci dessero una mano india
nostra vice a sinistra sarebbe meglio
ok ecco la prova guardi guardi mi sono
fatta signor gatto o armi in una
profonda marzo c'era anche una donna una
roba segreta di in basso a destra
vorrei vedere con che coraggio toma b100
tutti a padova a qualcosa di nuovo il
caldo attenzione e palle venga devo
stare all'ombra voglio stare qui fin qui
è facile in qua è fattibile occhio qua
ok va bene va da lei
[Risate]
no ce l'ho fatta guardi che bravo si
muovo proprio delle cose ad ovada giu
quasi si marcano è stato per il vice di
prima porca vacca mamma mia
sono passato anch'io ecco ci guardi
quindi qui sotto aspetti che completino
di far qua il cactus e pericoloso uccide
no ce l'ho fatta ho vinto bravissimo
sono stato gravissimo mi sono impegnato
non mi sono impegnato di lancio di certo
dov'è che si deve arrivare non da destra
vada vada io vada da mamma mia cosa ho
fatto
quindi come ha fatto arrivare lì lei non
ascona ma non fossero saltate come ha
fatto lei dava a sinistra si sta bene
adesso salti di ed deve fare quello che
pensa qui su si
bravo va da bravo dai non va bene venga
giorno o pazzo se si buttano giù che
caldo no no vabbè allora salti
attenzione che c'è il giallo era lì si
sceglierà di sabbia cacchio ciò fa
signor gatto lasciamo perdere questo
gioco ho notato che queste falle quanti
ne uccidono
siccome lo bloccano ma non ti uccidono
varie diceva ragazzi sia arrivando
mammamia signor gatto pure lei grave
sono approfittato
va bene io non esco più superati anche
quel punto vada vada bestie giu ma c'è
il vento che mi spinge a capire il brano
sarà il cazzo bravo bravo non mi hai è
mamma mia l'avrei fatta fuori io livello
9 ne mancano due ci siamo
questo lo vedo bello incasinata
guardi il maestro veneto problema e
quelle veramente difficile comunque
complimenti vada vada da bravo ragazzo
in basso paravo salti del muro
bravissimo e adesso è adesso deve andare
a destra bravi esa mars ii olari
monsignor gatto non so che dirle
complimenti bravissimo a me per i boss
battle questa pancarrè ecco fatto lei il
problema è ora che facciamo
avremo è la puzzola la puzzola non credo
ne la bussola stavo scherzando è
arrivato un subscriber si fa ha attivato
l'esplosivo mano ma scusami ma che serve
le scrivo sia nuovo esplosivo forse
bisogna tirarla sull'esplosivo problema
è un incubo lo fa prendere a lei
capitolo è coesa altro siamo qua a
battesimo non funziona signor gatto
socio vada su è bravo ma da subito
subito bravissimo bravissimo ma lei è un
grande
senza di lei dove saremo a quest'ora
adesso mamma mia e niente mi abbassa il
neo picchia la puzzola anodi quasi
romanzi di qua guarda che quante morti
ed è per forza ma il 50 nel nostro
sempre su 40 40 perfetto buon natale
salve è papà si scivola o notare ha
detto siamo partiti benissimo la paita
l'altro non vedo neanche gli ostacoli
capito totalmente è perché tutto è
ancora uno va lavata non capiscono anche
dove sono i punti morti parco demonio ma
si rende conto che questo è il primo
livello signor gatto può capire il
proprio il primo livello del terzo mondo
dai vada vada bravissimo va da mamma mia
ragazzi se va bene va bene se non ci
fossimo noi uno con l'altro siamo dove
andiamo
vada come vada
ok lenovo sbagliato io faccio gente ma
che mi ha fatto male d'izzia non lo so
ci vede vede lordo è visto tutto
ghiacciare non ce l'ho fatta guardi qua
no la puzzola la puzzola è la mia ti ha
visto ma ha lanciato le cose rumore alla
fine abbiamo capito che era un nemico
solo adesso l'ho capito che anche chi è
nemico tra l'altro no niente mi son
dimenticato che mi lanciava le cose
quando lo stare fermo landolt e le ferme
non so fermo è arrivata fino a da me la
bomba dell'abruzzo la pensa pensi lei
come sommesso io lasci dell'acqua ma non
ho capito se bisogna arrivare dopo bravo
va da lei sottovaso e freddo c'è scritto
eh vabbè che facciamo
mi sa che non si può rimanere troppo in
acqua va bene
chiudiamo infatti occhio occhio rosso
vivo ottimo noti ormai dice fuoco però
non ci salgo sopra che siano problemi di
riattivare il tasto non la bussola ce
l'ho fatta guardi bravissimo come aiuto
aiuto non posso stare fermo né scendere
e salire e scendere e salire rimango qua
mammamia avvenga l'ultima volta ci provi
dai questo livello è facile cosa le fa
credere che non lo sia va bene non si
può andare sia tutto giu avevo guardato
lei pensando così io ok ok lei è nato da
una parte e dall altra ottima per farli
venerdì quando è difficile io non ce
l'ho fatta ma la vedo vede quanto è
difficile 109 facilissimo si fa e che
bisogna sputare aspettare il momento
giusto per aumentare la visibilità
ok
ma porca a lei fatto bravo ma l'avevo
neanche guardato verso le speranze ma
lodato qui 45 mammamia 63 ma come
prodotto sia che invece meloni meno del
tutto è possibile
vabbè ma perché siamo morti tante volte
all'inizio che 4
mamma mia bagno francia freddo bisogna
far così ciao mamma mia
fico a mamma guarda con due recuperi
come siamo esperti e incredibile rifà no
non si va adeguato e dove devo andare
scusami bisogna andare a prendere il bus
o ed io seguo bene non so come
ringraziarla tora corra sati bravo o
muoia perché se no non so più come cosa
fare guardi mamma mia mamma mia non
muoia mai mai shifty bravo va bene va
bene non è vero così si ma era una
cazzata ok ho premuto grazie buon natale
grazie un'ora e mezza per passare la
pacifica maschile salti no non si può
fare faccio io prego magari lo devo
riprendere per andare su no scusi davis
saltare a destra ci stare verso sinistra
andare sulla piattaforma esattamente
così mamma mia signor gatto guardi qui
tardi i credibile io non capisco da cruz
il won ma dove ma dove è lì dove è qui
così così per una cagata
ma non avevo capito io è un ora che è
implicato e capire le cose studio vada
vada vinca lei sporco demonio ce l'ha
fatta ma da bar bravissimo bravissimo
rischio piano piano
noi adesso ma adesso quando fece pensare
deve saltare città né no papà ma
impossibile perché si scivola lì e mi
sono reso conto
mamma mia che lei è pazzo lei ha fatto
cose incredibili che misero ero sicuro
che fosse una piattaforma quella lì va
bene come ma lei ogni tanto fa robe va
dalla lascio andare ci provo ci provi
l'ultima volta e ogni tanto fa cose che
non so spiegare
bravissimo bellissima porca vacca ma
adesso sono diventati molto più
aggressivi pupazzi di neve o sbaglio noi
una riflessione molto bene bravo bravo e
forca vacca adesso sono dei cecchini
così no vabbè la chiediamo un ultimo
nunzio da chi o da lei per l'ugl orsino
al gatto addicted che sono tra i miei
amici
va bene come non detto grappoli non
ringrazia la ringrazio signora siamo
arrivati ad un punto che ci avrei
scommesso una lira su di noi va bene
così io ti ringrazio per avis e questo
video ci vediamo al prossimo con il
signor gatto se ce la farà mai a fare
questo livello non credete
non prendo anch'io però spero che mi sia
piaciuto iscrivetevi anche al cane in un
piatto ci vediamo in un prossimo video
da ragazzi
[Musica]